[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue de merci
d'être avec nous pour ce premier
rendez-vous d'auditions publiques donc
cette nouvelle émission que vous propose
chaque lundi désormais les chaînes
parlementaires
avec l' agence france-presse c'est avec
le figaro d'ailleurs nous sommes
installés ici dans le magnifique studio
du figaro est le premier invité
d'auditions publiques et brice hortefeux
bonsoir soit député européen et
conseiller de laurent wauquiez merci
d'être avec nous vous allez donc vous
soumettre aux questions de nos
journalistes est également un peu plus
tard dans l'émission vous le verrez deux
parlementaires qui viendront sans doute
peut-être corriger je ne sais pas
certaines de vos propres en tous les cas
apporter une contradiction
je vous laisse la surprise bien sûr
brise renault anticipe et peut-être
qu'ils sont totalement d'accord avec
marilou berry sont quand même un peu de
l'opposition pour sortir des sentiers
battus alors nous verrons cela tout à
l'heure alors les sujets bien sûr ne
manquent pas avec les difficultés de
l'exécutif même si aujourd'hui
l'exécutif nous fait des promesses avec
la présentation de son budget dé
discuter de la droite également qu'ils
se divisent et bien sûr il y avait les
impatiences des français donc votre
l'audition publique
brice hortefeux commence sous la
houlette de nos deux confrères qui sont
là yves thréard du figaro on saura arias
de la sp pardon du budget justement
d'abord puisque donc l'elysée matignon
bien sûr bercy affirme que le pouvoir
d'achat des français sera dopé l'an
prochain 6 milliards d'euros est ce que
vous croyez à ces bonnes nouvelles pour
les ménages
oui c'était ses classiques en était le
nouveau monde ressemble beaucoup à
l'ancien c'est un budget
on qu'on pourrait qualifier de
sucré-salé c'était il ya l'enveloppent
des douceurs c'était 1 6 milliard et du
bon quand même alors l'enveloppent des
douceurs c'est-à-dire l'annoncent
effectivement 2,6 milliards d'effort qui
ça fait et puis il y a le côté salé qui
correspond mieux à la réalité vers
darmanin qui a longtemps partagé votre
route à l'ump puis au républicain disait
dans les colonnes du monde ce soir que
c'était un budget qui présentait une
baisse d'impôts comme jamais on n'avait
vu depuis 10 ans 11 en 2007
weeds est il donc dans ces milliards
pour les parce qu'il ya aussi d'un
milliard pour les entreprises et c'est
ça on parlait des particuliers ces 3 8
milliards en réalité pour la taxe
d'habitation et les cotisations
salariales autour de 700 millions mais
là évidemment où le bât blesse c'est que
ce chiffre est sympathique mais il faut
pas oublier la réalité c'est-à-dire une
augmentation massive de tout ce qui est
carburant et puisque ça c'est 2
milliards et la c 4 centimes et 7
centimes diesel et fait des additions
les fumeurs donné ça veut dire que c'est
pas mal
si par malheur exactement si par malheur
vous êtes fumeur conducteur diesel très
peu traité retraités les mains vous êtes
assaisonner pourtant déjoué attendait
qu'on ait le temps et en même temps vous
avez la même chose si vous êtes
malheureusement père de famille
nombreuse et conducteur est fumeur est
bien là vous êtes une deuxième catégorie
dans lequel l'ange est bien arrangé pour
autant verger donc antérieur au coup ça
l'est tout ça et pourtant le ministère
de l'intérieur qui gagne un pourcentage
conséquent pour son nouveau du jane de
même pour la justice de même pour la
défense est-ce que tout simplement ça ne
va pas dans le bon sens ces housses de
budget pour ces ministères régaliens qui
vous tiennent à coeur
mais si vous êtes en train de
m'expliquer qu'il ya une hausse de la
dépense publique contrairement à tout ce
qui avait été indiqué ça c'est exact
opuscule secteur la baisse de la dépense
publique contraire
moi ce qui avait été annoncé la dépense
publique elle augmentait elle augmente
beaucoup elles augmentent de solutions
pour ça mais on a été à l'augmenter de
25 ans après ça veut dire qu'il y à une
dérive encore est aujourd'hui sur la
dépense publique
contrairement test j'ai pas tout ce que
je veux sur le plan général ça manque
d'audace il ya pas les économies qui
sont prévus et surtout promise par le
président de la république c'est ce que
vous êtes en train de nous dire si vous
êtes en train de m'interroger de manière
générale sur ce que je pense du bilan
c'est ça des manuels macron aujourd'hui
je vous le dis c'est très simple c'est à
la fois le bazar fiscale c'est la
pagaille migratoires c'est l'hécatombe
politique c'est noir reportrice et le
plantage économiques parce que c'est la
réalité
l'hécatombe écoutez je porte de les
différents points oui mais aucun soin
enfin je suis engagé dans la vie
publique depuis assez longtemps moi j'ai
passé l'âge de l'époque où on était
content parce qu'il fallait être content
pour parce qu'on est devait être pour
moi si tu ça c'est terminé pour moi ça
ouais je dis ce que je constate que
j'observe
est ce que je pense hécatombe politique
qui secoue les qu'est ce que c'est que
ce système ou en 15 mois
vous avez six ministres qui partent soit
sous la contrainte soit parce qu'ils
l'annoncent un matin soit en donnant
leur calendrier comme un salarié pour
ses congés écoutez c'est assez original
comme situation jour une intégration par
exemple du ministre de l'intérieur vous
avez occupé cette fonction oui c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que ce qui est tout à
fait normal quand j'observe l'action du
ministre de l'intérieur
j'essaie d'éviter de tomber dans des
caricatures parce que j'ai connu je me
suis je mesure la difficulté qu'il y à
être ministre de l'intérieur et je ne
doute pas pour être tout à fait clair de
la bonne volonté et de gérard collomb
mais lloris
d'ailleurs il peut rester des jours mois
six a dit qu'il partirait après les
élections européennes qui sont en mai
est ce que il te reste emily's à
l'intérieur ce que je vous dis c'est que
la démarche de gérard collomb annonçant
sa volonté d'être candidat aux
municipales à lyon s'inscrivait
certainement dans un souci de sincérité
mais l'opinion publique attend à juste
titre que celui qui est chargé de la
protection qui est chargé de la sécurité
qui est chargé de limites des questions
migratoires qui est chargé de la lutte
contre le terrorisme le soin à temps
plein dans ses actes mais aussi dans sa
tête et je vous donne juste
je vous donne juste cette référence
personnelle puisque comme vous l'avez
rappelé j'ai exercé ses fonctions en
2010 je m'apprêtais à être candidat tête
de liste aux élections régionales en
ouverte
oui et à l'occasion d'un rencontre à
l'elysée le président de la république
je crois qu' à l'heure qu'il y avait le
premier ministre nicolas sarkozy et
françois fillon donc et m'ont demandé de
ne pas l'être
pas simplement ce que les chances
étaient modestes pourraient tout à fait
honnête mais aussi parce que ni
considéré que le rôle du ministre de
l'intérieur c'est de se consacrer
totalement tout en étant à l'écouté de
la population n'étant pas simplement
enfermé à beauvau en étant bien sûr sur
le terrain et sur son terrain mais que
cela pouvait porter préjudice et alex
faut qu'ils partent du ministère
l'intérieur ou est-ce qu'il peut rester
jusqu'à la fin jusqu'aux élections
européennes c'est une décision du
président de la république
et maintenant que gérard collomb
lui-même a dit qu'il allait partir
peut-être qu'il nous a fait réfléchir
aux son calendrier comme je voudrais
revenir sur le ministère de l'intérieur
parce que c'est un ministère que vous
connaissez bien et paul l'a dit il ya
qu'à mettre des moyens supplémentaires
quelques 2500 fonctionnaires en plus une
augmentation de 2 et demi pour cent du
budget est-ce que et bien là il n'y a
pas un effort qui tout le monde
s'accorde à dire qu'il faut mettre le
paquet là dessus c'est pareil d'ailleurs
sur la justice puisque mes jeux
vous lit n'importe quel gouvernement
quel qu'il soit de quelques sensibilités
quelques sensibilités qu'il appartienne
serait contraint de renforcer les moyens
du ministère l'intérieur c'est pas
d'ailleurs à mes yeux mais il peut y
avoir débat tellement en termes
d'effectifs même si la question des
effectifs se pose c'est en termes
d'équipement c'est en termes d'armement
c'est en termes de véhicules c'est en
termes technologiques
c'est en terme de formation votre mandat
mais c'était bien sûr c'était le cas
vous savez c'est nicolas sarkozy par
exemple qui avait décidé que le gilet
pare-balles serait d individualiser
jusque là ça tournait cti ce le passé en
selon les équipes
c'est des choses comme ça qu'il faut
faire ça veut pas dire qu'il n'ya pas
des marges de progression dans certains
domaines mais je veux je le dis oui les
moyens du ministère de l'intérieur et du
ministère de la justice font partie et
des impératifs
si l'on veut faire face à l'évolution
très préoccupants de la délinquance est
naturellement du terreau d'hécatombe
politique est là précisément au moment
où le chef de l'état connaît un trou
d'air dont dans l'est dans les sondages
il est à peu près entre françois
hollande et nicolas sarkozy quinze mois
après le début de leur mandat
est ce que ça vous inquiète finalement
cette chute de popularité dont on a
l'impression qu'elle est quasiment
systématique est ce que vous vous dites
est ce que en étant si un peu plus l'air
entre guillemets va-t-il pouvoir faire
des réformes réformes auxquelles vous
aspiriez me semble-t-il
ça ne me surprend pas parce que vous
savez là aussi l'expérience permet de
lire c'est que la communication peut
abuser un temps mais peut pas juger tout
le temps mais ça veut dire quand on dit
qu'on fait du sarkozy
non seulement en la matière il faut pas
de la communication et puis après ils
vont pouvoir parler et la réalité c'est
qu'il ya une très grande habileté habité
pendant la campagne présidentielle où il
ya eu comme les médias d'ailleurs la
diège street une sorte de hold up sur
présidentielle qu'il n'y a pas eu de
débat présidentiel notamment sa marine
le pen il ya eu un débat face à marine
le pen il n'y a pas eu de débat le
candidat de la droite républicaine qui
honnêtement espérer gagner et je le
soutenais n'a pas pu évoquer son
programme son projet tout a été occulté
par tout ce que vous savez donc c était
une question une période de hold up
démocratique mais hold up quand même les
lui-même je crois avait dicté par
effraction il me semble qu'il avait dit
évoquer ça c'est une doxa de l'action
manquerait donc il y a eu une très
grande habileté de communication
aujourd'hui il exerce dans l'exercice du
pouvoir
on s'aperçoit que 1 il ya des multiples
erreurs de communication et 2 que les
résultats ne sont pas au rendez au
rendez vous est ce que c'est vraiment
est ce que c'est vraiment des erreurs de
communication ou c'est un manque
d'humilité comme l'a dit à son propos le
ministre l'intérieur
est ce que ce sont pas des erreurs
plutôt d'attitude de comportement quand
on n'interpelle un jeune horticulteur
par exemple à l'elysée qui cherche un
emploi quand on dit que les français
aient bien sont réfractaires les gaulois
sont réfractaires aux réformes
on n'en valait alors les plans il ya je
vous le dis je le pense bien sûr des
erreurs moi je vous appelez ça de de
situer le comportement de communication
efficiency surtout sur le fond parce
qu'on me pose et il n'y a pas la
question pourquoi pourquoi tout d'un
coup il y à pas et cette baisse qui est
une baisse assez spectaculaire est tout
simplement parce que les résultats sont
pas au rendez-vous sont pas permettre ne
sont pas encore en attendait permettez
moi quand même de rester quelques
instants là dessus vous savez quand on a
quand on observe la réalité je veux pas
être schématique je veux pas être
caricatural j'essaie d'être le plus
honnête mais en réalité tout ce qu'ils
auraient dû diminuer augmenter et tout
ce qu'ils auraient dû augmenter à
diminuer si je vous donne quelques
exemples que je partais au stif
mais ce jeune quelques saisons qu'est ce
qu'ils auraient dû diminuer et qu'
augmenter les prélèvements obligatoires
ils ont augmenté où ils ont stagné sur
les trois premiers trimestres de 2010 8
il ya une augmentation des prélèvements
obligatoires
je sais il faut bien comprendre que
aujourd'hui en 2018
les français ont travaillé jusqu'au 27
juillet pour payer des impôts
cotisations et taxes
il y a eu aucune amélioration ça s'est
même détérioré la dépense publique on
nous l'évoquions à quelques instants
elles auraient dû diminuer elle continue
à augmenter encore une fois de 0 26%
l'année prochaine le chômage ils
auraient dû diminuer comme dans tous les
pays d'europe
comme dans tous les grands pays
industrialisés nous en sommes au chômage
à 9,2 pour cent le moyenne de l'union
européenne ces 8,2 tout en chef de
l'état non mais je tiens minutes sur le
chômage il faut bien comprendre que nous
sommes aujourd'hui une anomalie
nous sommes une anomalie dans les grands
pays est ce que la du stress que vous
reconnaissez donc il est en parfait
responsable à 100 % mais ça y est le
chef
il est fait donc selon l'expression
chirac est bien connue qui ferait arts
s'en souvient certainement vrai c'est
fait pour chez fait ça veut donc dire
qu'il porte la responsabilité de ce qui
est comme je me souviens de beaucoup de
choses parce que j'ai quand même perdu
beaucoup de cheveux points que dallas
pourront partager ce que vous venez de
dire qui juste ça fait 40 ans qu'on est
dans le chômage de masse ça fait 40 ans
qu'on n'a pas voté un budget en
équilibre
ça fait 40 ans qu'on a de la dette mais
qu'est-ce qui se creuse mais il n'ya pas
que ma gueule macron il y avait
également socialiste c'est-à-dire
finalement m
macron c'est comme les autres la
négation de son élection alors
puisqu'elles sont des mois sans cervelle
que je constate son élection ça devait
être le nouveau monde ça devait être un
bouleversement en réalité vous savez on
a tous compris
emmanuel macron le en même temps ça veut
dire ni oui ni non ça veut dire mi figue
mi raisin cela lui a trouvé son
expression le milieu du chemin ça veut
dire michel michaut presse hortefeux
vous aviez peut-être au départ où il ya
un peu plus d'an une forme de
bienveillance pour le chef de l'état
oui ou non mais c'est pas une question
l'arrière veillance est légal à l'égard
du chef de l'état c'est le souhait que
notre pays réussissent s'accordent donc
moi je suis pas dans le rouge reçu au
sentiment donc et bien que ça ne
marcherait donc n'ai pas répondu à la
question de paul est ce que ça vous
inquiète pour le pays aveu bien sûr
est-ce qu'on peut réformer mais entre le
20 et 30% seulement d'opinions positives
par excès sûr que c'est un boulet s'est
fait bouffer denis plassard cette fois
c'est françois hollande ce sera celui de
maniema chromebook rennais mais bien sûr
c'est un boulet bien sûr que c'est un
boulet d'avoir une croissance et qui est
simplement de 0 4% sur et de premier
trimestre et une croissance de 2 4%
c'est à dire et qui nous met au niveau
de l'italie qui est deux fois plus
faible que la moyenne de l'union
européenne deux fois plus faible que le
portugal ou le l'allemagne trois fois
plus fait que l'espagne futur des fonds
vers les états unis bien sûr c'est très
préoccupant quand je vous rappelle ces
éléments sur la croissance mais qui peut
s'en réjouir au contraire c'est très
préoccupant alors que la croissance
commencer à repartir et çà et là elle
est bloquée brice hortefeux voudrait
qu'on fasse un petit pas de côté il ya
un sujet important
on a tant que président de la république
s'exprime dessus c'est celui de l'islam
le gouvernement auquel vous avez
appartenu et le président de la
république sous lequel vous avez servi à
tenter d'organiser le slam
on a eu le conseil français du culte
musulman c'est aussi semble-t-il la
volonté du président de la république
actuel est ce que ce n'est pas une
fausse bonne idée sachant que c'est
compliqué est impossible d'organiser qui
plus est une religion j'ai vu ce que
certaines grandes plumes écrivait sur ce
sujet
et j'ai un point de désaccord avec ce
que j'ai lu et un point de désaccord
peut-être avec certains de mes amis
politiques moi je crois à l'organisation
de des religions quand vous êtes
ministre des cultes ce que j'ai été vous
avez un interlocuteur avec en la
religion catholique vous avez
l'archevêque le cardinal archevêque de
paris et vous avez le primat des gaules
quand vous êtes ministre des cultes vous
avez des interlocuteurs pour la religion
juive du grand rabbin au président du
consistoire vous avez des interlocuteurs
vous avez la même chose avec la
fédération protestante avec le président
de la fédération protestante ce sont des
églises éclaté mais il ya un
interlocuteur
elles sont diverses j'insiste bien là
dessus elles sont diverses et églises
protestantes mais vous avez un
interlocuteur et il était à mon avis
extrêmement dangereux que n'aimiez pas
aussi une organisation de l'islam de
l'islam de france et nicolas sarkozy et
j'ai appliqué cette politique et non pas
l'islam en france dont vous seriez la
demande pour moi je souhaite je
soutiendrai l'organisation du culte
parce que je mesure aussi localement
dans ma région je vais j'ai un président
qui est une des cas des conseils
régionaux gérés par un turc et donc j'ai
une organisation anatole ronaldo quand
il ya un souci
enfin le poster ou verne mais quand il
ya un souci quand il ya une
préoccupation quand il ya besoin de
dialogue à la table et il faut qu'il y
ait un terme à la dernière question pour
cette partie brice hortefeux l'écrivain
yann moix riac mais moi que ça a soulevé
nouvelle polémique avec des propos anti
flics la semaine dernière comment une
ex-miss de l'intérieur que vous êtes a
réagi par rapport technique en cause en
gros il disait que fric mais policiers
avaient peur peur d'aller dans les
quartiers et manquer de courage
qu'est ce que ça vous a inspiré pardon
la peur est un sentiment humain et j'ai
rencontré mois des policiers qui étaient
qu'ils avaient peur j'avais rencontré
des policiers notamment à grenoble a
quant à lui a eu de graves incidents
mais la manière dont cela a été exprimé
est totalement inadmissible c'est moi
j'ai vu une règle très simple
et quand on attaquait la politique ça me
paraissait injuste je portais plat nous
en été
en effet je les fais succès sera
toujours opposé clan ce qu'ont notamment
contre des rappeurs qui tenait des
propos hallucinants deux mois je pense
que le ministre de l'intérieur devrait
déposer pain dès lors que l'analyse
juridique l'encouragera à le faire parce
que c'est aussi cet élément là mais si
l'année les juridique le permet oui il
devrait porter plainte
alors il ya une autre polémique qui a
surgi ce week-end on a rapporté des
propos tenus par monsieur marcel campion
qui organise tous les hivers est tous là
au moment de noël à marcher à paris des
propos où il disait que finalement la
ville de paris la municipalité était
noyauté même si le mot n'a pas été
exprimées par des homosexuels
donc avec des avec ces termes les termes
choisis en l'occurrence c'est l'état
maintenant qui a repris à son compte le
marché de noël via le musée du louvre
est ce que vous estimez que ces propos
sont incompatibles avec l'exploitation
va marcher mais lourde surtout avec
l'argent de l'état
oui ces deux sujets qui ne sont pas liés
danser le campion s'est exprimé il y à
une polémique
il a démenti il a démenti les prés d'un
an
je crois qu'il ya une plainte qui a été
déposée la justice tranchera
concernant le marché neuf mois j'ai
regretté que la qu'il est été annulé
dans la forme qui existaient
précédemment parce que je pense que
c'est un moment de fête qui était pas
simplement aux loisirs au jour
moi je suis partisan que ce soit
maintenu très bien voilà c'est clair
merci merci monsieur merci deuxième
partie est tout de suite d'auditions
publiques avec nos deux parlementaires
qui font leur entrée sur le plateau
[Musique]
bonsoir messieurs installez-vous merci
beaucoup c'est un mal être avec nous
vous êtes sénateur socialiste du val
d'oise est à vos côtés jean michel
faubert vous êtes député la république
en marge de ce cinéma et vous avez été
le patron du raid vous avez écouté brice
hortefeux ancien ministre de l'intérieur
argumenté on peut peut-être d'abord
rebondir sur ce qu'il a dit sur la
police avec quand même une forme de
satisfecit aucun gouvernement
aujourd'hui ne pourrait évidemment ne
pas augmenter les effectifs
c'est un motif de satisfaction vous
pourriez peut-être avoir à coeur
peut-être le défendre également la
politique du ministre de l'intérieur
concernant les quartiers alors certes
certes
aucun gouvernement ne pourrait se passer
de l'augmentation des effectifs
sauf que sauf que ça a été fait sous
nicolas sarkozy et sauf que ça a été ça
a été repris après sous votre magistère
on a manqué de douze mille policiers qui
avaient qui qu'il n'était plus dans
leurs fonctions
donc ça fait à l'époque où on a on est
on est rentrés donc danser dans ces
attentats terroristes que vous n'avez
pas connu sous le magistère aux fortes
forte heureusement pour vous bien c'est
des effectifs qui manquait tant vous dès
aujourd'hui vous êtes obligé de
rattraper leurs effectifs perdu les
effectifs ont été pour être tout à fait
honnête on comment on était comme en a
commencé à rattraper ses effectifs la
soul
sous le sous la gauche est sous l'ancien
gouvernement
on va rester honnête complètement mais
devra dire mais non pas du tout pas du
tout mais pas mais pas assez alors
aujourd'hui on est en déficit en déficit
d'effectif et en particulier sur les
quartiers sur la lutte contre le
terrorisme sur le renseignement à peu
près partout et ça on le doit aux à
l'héritage qu'on a eu des uns et des
autres alors là dessus vous vous
revendiquez
je suis un petit peu déçu parce que je
me demandais ce que ce soit pas ces
petites histoires politicienne est tous
à penser que votre expérience vous
amener à voir le recul là dessus parce
que vous avez été très incomplet dans
votre présentation
votre présentation où les animaux il n'y
a pas eu d'attentât pendant que j'étais
effectivement ministre oui il y en a pas
eu
et il ya aussi un autre élément c'est
que la délinquance qui augmentait savait
notamment les airs bien dansons personne
est atteinte aux biens comme ça qui
augmentait régulièrement sur la période
2010 2012 avait baissé donc pourquoi je
vous dis cela parce que bien sûr c'est
très facile vers les effectifs vous
auriez pu même dire d'ailleurs que les
35 heures avaient fait perdre lui
évidemment de 8000 emplois dans la
police aurait pu aussi l'évoquer mais
parce que ça après ça signifie quoi que
bien sûr il ya la question des effectifs
je prie je vous rejoins sur un point
c'est qu'il n'ya sans doute pas
aujourd'hui assez d'effectifs d'agents
infiltrés dans certains milieux pas
assez le nom quantitatif joue mais on
sait très bien que la lutte contre la
délinquance et pas simplement ça la
lutte contre al ahly 1 quand ce sont les
moyens cela nous l'évolution de la
technologie c'est un certain nombre
d'éléments de protection
c'est un ensemble tout ça mais vous
savez moi je vous prie suggère puiser
dans la majorité puis vous êtes bien
placé ou j'ai cru lire que vous aimeriez
est encore mieux placé mais vous devriez
demander à ce que l'on publie
régulièrement à nouveau les statistiques
que l'observatoire national délinquance
d'hommes tous les agrégats on les a pas
les gars c'est quand même très curieux
je vous devriez insisté sur le fait qu'
effectivement il faut travailler sur la
clim est la criminalité la criminalité
de voie publique faut travailler sur sur
sept ce type de délinquance là sauf que
pour travailler sur ce type de l'un
quand cela est effectivement j'ai été
patron du raid est plutôt policier
répressif
on va dire ça comme ça mais j'étais
aussi directeur départemental de la
sécurité publique et en guyane donc dans
un territoire difficile
et effectivement cette époque là il y
avait la mise en place de ce qu'on
appelle la police de proximité alors ce
n'est pas la panacée mais l'idée de
proximité est importante pourquoi parce
que pour être supprimé pour vaincre
j'allais y arriver merci de merci de me
le dire mais pour vaincre 7,7 ce
problème de criminalité de petite
délinquance
il faut être présent sur le terrain or
ça la baisse des effectifs est
effectivement la baisse des équipements
qui a commencé depuis longtemps et qui
est en train d'être rattrapé maintenant
sa date et sa date de votre magistère
napoli napoli oui nous affirmer une
chose mais on est en vous contredisez
alors parce que précisément la police de
proximité quand elle était mise en place
pourquoi elle a été arrêté sous sept
jours
d'abord proximité c'est un mot pardon
galvaudé touquet ce qui est contre la
proximité vous en connaissez vous qui
dit il faut une police d'éloignement
alors loin du tout par la proximité bien
précisément pour ramener l'ordre
la liste de proximité comme quand elle a
été créée c'était tellement un échec
toutes les statistiques de la
délinquance montrer que ça marchait pas
c'est pour cela qu'il a formulées chose
et il y avait une tendance je dis pas
que c'était la tendance qui était et
générales partout mais c'est facile à
faire j'ai fait remplacer pour ça que
j'ai mis en place des brigades spéciales
de talent n'a pas fonctionné si ça
n'aurait bien fonctionné parce que je
n'ai pas augmenté et fait quand j'étais
juste à d'abord complété moi je sais le
fait qu'ils avaient discuté mon collègue
fauvergue a eu du mal à dire que sous
françois hollande dans l'union
du mal 9000 policiers ont été créés je
veux moi je vais changer de sujet vous
êtes une personnalité reconnue respecté
de la droite française jusque là tout va
bien pour vous arrêter
je vais continuer vous allez voir ça se
passera très bien vous étiez aussi une
personnalité effectivement importante
aux côtés nicolas sarkozy maintenant
conseiller du président de votre parti
donc une personnalité qui compte
et moi quand je vois que dans l'europe
il y à une vague de nationalisme de
racisme avait quand même maintenant des
dirigeants des fonds d'état qui pose
problème d'un point de vue des droits de
l'homme je suis attristé parce que
effectivement quand vous êtes une grande
personnalité vous êtes un républicain
convaincu c'est trop que vous avez pas
su en tout cas d'abord garder hors bahn
je rappelle à la fois dans votre parti
le ppe et que vous n'avez pas su vous
vous même brice hortefeux
vous adoptez avec le parlement européen
la mesure et vous êtes abstenu et je
trouve que par rapport à l'image de la
droite aujourd'hui à la fois ce qui se
passe en europe
et puis dans votre parti certains qui
aimerait elle s'allie avec l'extrême
droite ou en tout cas à courir après
l'extrême droite
je trouve regrettable est dommage que ne
soyez pas vous même exprimé fortement
pour condamner la politique de monsieur
ban est votée comme d'ailleurs la
majorité du parlement européen donc
voilà ça c'est un regret donc cette
première question d'une réputation
subventions
vous avez raison peut-être de le
présenter comme cela vous voyez mais
c'est pas c'est pas un sujet qui était
simple en tout cas pour moi je me suis
posé beaucoup de questions
il ya un certain nombre d'éléments pas
répondre 10 en 5 secondes et un certain
nombre d'éléments qu'il faut prendre en
compte
premier élément est monsieur or ban que
je ne connais pas titre personnel j'ai
rencontré son ministre l'intérieur je
connais son milieu la justice peut être
l'avez vous même croisés parce qu'il
était ambassadeur de hongrie à paris
bref un certain nombre d'interlocuteurs
et notamment une sa secrétaire d'état
chargé des affaires européennes que j'ai
reçu aussi monsieur urban a rassemblé
dès le premier tour d'un de son scrutin
quarante neuf et aussi pour cent des
électeurs hongrois
je ne veux pas être cruel vis-à-vis de
vous ni même d'ailleurs vis-à-vis de
vous concernant la tendance comme ça ni
l'âme il vous aimez bien sûr mais bien
sûr mais ont franchement rassembler des
premiers tours d'un scrutin
un habitant de son pays sur deux qui
fait cela deuxième élément du recul de
l'état demandent encore il faut pas
expliquer aux hongrois et que ce sont
des abrutis
et puis ce qu'ils ont ordonné à leur
tête c'est parce que vous avez dit mais
il ya une tendance c'est parce que vous
avez aimé y attendait une tendance
sous-entendu sorbonne est épouvantable
ça veut donc dire que les hongrois sont
pas bien fin non il faut attendre il
faut respecter la démocratie deuxième
élément on est tous préoccupés autour de
cette table par la progression de
l'extrême mois dans toute l'europe
en hongrie le parti d'extrême ans
appelle le jobic c'est le seul pays
aujourd'hui dans lequel l'extrême droite
a été contenu le jeu bic a progressé de
0,2 pour cent c'est un élément
troisième élément moi je suis pas plus
royalistes que le roi
la commission européenne se rentrer dans
des détails techniques la commission
européenne elle n'a pas engagé
l'article 7 elle ne l'a pas engagé elle
a fait des remarques notamment sur la
séparation ou directement le respect de
la justice et elle a constaté qu'il y
avait une amélioration qui avait été
fait mais à côté de ça je vois que c'est
un rapport qui était pardonnez moi qui a
été déposée par une
verte néerlandaise qui est venu
d'ailleurs très très correctement elles
me voient pour m'expliquer maël et elle
n'était pas allée sur place c'est des
raps et des synthèses de rapports des
ong
j'observe aussi été soutenu par toute
l'extrême gauche
franchement je pense que ça l'embêté je
n'ai pas voté contre le rapport parce
que j'étais déçu par le fait que viktor
orban n'est pas abandonnée tendu la main
en disant j'entends ce qui est dit non
pas tant par la commission qui a pas de
procédure qui est engagée mais par le
parlement et je propose de ce qu'il n'a
pas fait ce qui explique ma position
accord je pense qu'à côté a bien sûr
honnête aux neiges d'antan sincère et
responsable dans l'argumentaire présenté
fait donc sorbonne un avantage et
contient l'extrême droite alors est ce
que cette dans les salles marche à
suivre
d'abord je rappelle qu'il fut un temps
avec jacques chirac où la france s'est
opposée à ce que l'autriche dirige
l'union européenne et c'est pas parce
qu'ils font 49%
cet argument je pense que l'europe si
c'est un aréna mais laissez-moi terminer
je vous ai laissé parler sauf que la
démocratie l'europe c'est aussi ces 50
pour doit porter et pouvoir dire
abandonner sur notre continent
la démocratie est avant tout et quand
vous nous dites qu'il contient si c'est
pour en reprenant l'extrait les propos
d'extrême droite qu'il contient
d'extrême droite
pour moi c'est très pratique ses
addictions non je pense action arguments
vous collectivement on préfère large
l'original à la copie ballon alors dans
ces cas là alors moi ces combats soit
l'original à la copie
enfin ces jeux combats l'extrême droite
qu'elle se soit l'original à la copie
moi j'ai pas la différence entre vous et
moi j'ai non je vous dis rien point
commun c'est que vous n'avez embauche
chez moi j'ai voté et les sanctions
contre la pologne
donc la pologne vaughan dans la fiction
la commission européenne vers 2h20 dans
la commission la commission européenne
mais est-ce que vous êtes un jour corps
balle reste dans votre groupe ppe moi je
suis pour qu'il reste bien sûr parce que
je vais dire très facile de rester avec
vous nommer mais vous avez aussi mettre
dehors
c'est aussi on essaie de d'extrémisme et
même quand on est à l'intérieur on peut
faire évoluer
moi je crois d'abord sur juin diallo
mais moi je préfère qu'il reste au sein
du ppe messieurs je voudrais vous poser
une question sur laquelle vous êtes
retrouvé avec le front national c'est là
le fait de s'opposer
à la fin de l'état d'urgence que nous
avons voté et nous avons voté 7 701
d'état d'urgence en passant des outils
l'état d'urgence dans le droit constant
en particulier les visites domiciliaires
qui me tiennent à coeur parce que c'est
un élément important que ces contrôles
transition pour par les acquisitions
illustrative il enseigne perquisition
démonstratif tout à fait exact vous y
est opposée or je ne comprends pas cette
attitude là puisque en septembre 2015 il
y avait une ppl un projet de loi déposée
au sénat des poussées par monsieur bah
on dit monsieur baou monsieur bah ce
monsieur monsieur bah c'est pas la
commission de retrait aujourd'hui et
monsieur retailleau qui demandait
c'était en décembre 2015 et qui
demandait à ce que l'état d'urgence soit
stoppée et que les instruments de l'état
d'urgence passe dans le droit constant
alors vous l'avez rêvé en septembre 2015
ça n'a pas été très faim parce que il ya
eu des attentats après et nous ne
l'avons fait en arrivant au pouvoir
je veux dire moi ce qui me ce qui me
dépasse un peu et vous disiez que vous
n'êtes pas un homme politique à
l'ancienne vous vous êtes beau t'es pas
content pour voter contre mais vous
opposer à tout quand même hein ce qui me
ce qui me ce qui m'interpelle un peu
c'est que dans ce domaine là vous
preniez avant une situation que vous ne
prenez pas après parce que justement
elle est proposée par les autres et là
vous avez qu'on voit là vous êtes un peu
en contradiction avec ce que vous avez
dit ah c'est un sujet qui est déjà
derrière nous parce que c'était passé
j'étais toujours constant mais dans le
cadre lui la lutte avec le monde mais
j'en avais parlé avec frédéric péchenard
et une analyse sur ce sujet le directeur
général de la police l'ancien directeur
général de la police nationale est
certainement bien connu il y avait un
certain en d'éléments qui était positif
il y avait des éléments qui étaient très
incomplet voilà et c'est pour ça que à
l'époque je m'étais exprimé sur le com
rappelant la position qui était qui
était la mienne qui était qui était la
nôtre mais je comprends très bien qu'ils
aient eu des quais eu des débats je vous
dis
l'ancien directeur de la police
nationale avait sa propre analyse sur ce
sujet j'étais mal me souviens évoque la
question parfois de vote commun il a
raison pose la question comment il a
évoqué entre les républicains l'extrême
droite sur la question de la sortie d'
état d'urgence mais j'ai envie de dire
également et ça pose le problème c'est
que sur d'autres lois au sénat je vois
la plus qu'au marché la droite voter
main dans la main et c'était une des
vraie question c'est est-ce qu'à la fin
il n'y a pas plus tôt cette forme
d'alliance parce que si je prends
parcours sup
la sélection des étudiants tout le monde
vous l'avez voté ensemble
si je reprends la loi asile immigration
l'article 5 monsieur le député monsieur
le député européen vous ai voté ensemble
et avec le front national
le fan que nous avons aujourd'hui c'est
que il ya effectivement une gauche qui
essaye de se reconstruire et nous avons
beaucoup de travail
j'en conviens mais je me suis dit et
c'est du chantage et la démonstration
est il la démocratie c'est effectivement
d'avoir des projets différents et
malheureusement aujourd'hui et c'est
monsieur copé qui l'a dit coupez dit
maintenant macron c'est le présent de
droite que nous attendions et donc c'est
peut-être aussi là un élément sur les
politiques économiques sociales quand je
vois le budget gelé dit sur
l'immigration joly sur parcours sup
vous avez cette connivence et je le vois
moi concrètement au sénat vous avez dû
en urgence avec l'extrême l'extrême
gauche et l'extrême droite à l'assemblée
à l'assemblée nationale les droits les
trois entités qui est des biens nous des
réseaux bien et les gosses qui ont donné
au monde débarquent des choses
totalement erronée c'est ce qui s'est
passé il ya assez de connaissances entre
le parti socialiste et l'extrême - je
vous ai interdit le dirigeant juste un
mot nous c'est dan son gré commission
denquête vous vous en faites une aile se
saborde c'est le temple solaire en
quatre jours sans aucun rapport c'est du
jamais vu dans la démocratie française
une commission denquête avec zéro ligne
à la fin de cet endroit aussi le
résultat de l enquête judiciaire qui est
important surtout quand vous
j'ai dit tout à l'heure que c'était plus
le président de droite qu'il attendait
parce que ça me saoule je vous dis les
choses du maquereau et votre président à
l'évidence non et je vais t'expliquer
pourquoi pas les juger pourquoi ces
panneaux président parce qu un président
de droite c'est pas celui qui
s'acharneraient sur les retraités comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui
les présidents de droite un président de
droite
il protégerait les retraités c'est pas
non plus un président qui accablerait
comme c'est le cas depuis un certain
nombre d'années d'ailleurs et les
classes moyennes au contraire elle les
protègeraient et les défendre et il est
un président de droite c'est pas celui
qui démantèlent ray la politique
familiale au contraire un président de
droite il en assurait la promotion donc
tout ceci pour vous dire que monsieur
mâcon n'est pas un président de se voir
pelé s'est trompé alors je veux dire que
la saison avait réussi il se maquille on
l'a fait s'est précisée mais ça revient
ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure c'est à
lyon on s'arrête au milieu du chemin
je pense que la gauche comme chacun s'en
aller vers la droite et la gauche se
rejettent le président est mal macro ça
veut dire que le manuel que qu'emmanuel
macron et placer sur l'échiquier
politique ni à droite ni à gauche mais
est placé de manière centrale et l'avis
des français mais aussi entre deux
chaises ce qu'ils se doivent pas du tout
c'est ce que disent ils avec autant de
temps avec son premier tour là
j'aimerais qu'il y ait une alliance
entre la gauche et la droite partagent
pas son nom d'années le parc de l'état
quand le ce gouvernement-là fait
financer la suppression de l' isf par
les plus pauvres oui je suis je combats
souvent là ça n'a rien à voir avec la
politique que pourrait mener l'équipe à
lui qu'un retrait c'est la démocratie
sur l'immigration monsieur
monsieur brice hortefeux vous étiez vous
avez été ministre de l'immigration et
ensuite vous êtes reparti au ministère
l'intérieur en absorbant d'ailleurs ce
ministère de l'immigration pour des
questions diverses et variées et surtout
pour les questions parce que ça ne
fonctionnait pas à l'époque où vous
étiez ministre de l'immigration ministre
de l'intérieur moi j'étais chef de
service à l'office de la police aux
frontières et j'étais sous directeur de
la police aux frontières
donc sur des problèmes d'immigration
important nous avons voté la loi asile
et migrations qui est une loi qui est
équilibré sur le droit d'asile et qui
est équilibré sur le retour des
étrangers qui n'ont pas vocation à
rester sur le territoire national c'est
cet équilibre là qui est important je
pense que c'est quelque chose a prôné
l'equilibre votre groupe jeune en tant
qu une chose sur les migrations de la
part de votre groupe
c'est l'immigration choisie et ça c'est
un c'est un leitmotiv qui apparaît
depuis depuis longtemps alors
l'émulation choisi ça marche sur des
pays comme le canada comme la nouvelle
zélande un peu un peu l'australie parce
que c'est des pays qui sont qui n'ont
pas de passé colonialiste et qui sont
assez éloignées des milieux de 2 ou les
migrants partis des pays des pays de
départ question maintenant la question
est là ma question est la suivante sur
ceux sur cette immigration choisie
comment ferez vous le jour où on arrive
aux quotas que vous décidez admettons
que que vous êtes pouvoir on arrive aux
quotas que vous décidez et le malien qui
va se trouver à cailloux le nigérien où
le houleux la personne la personne la
corne de l'afrique qui doit venir en
france va se dire bah non j'avais prévu
d'aller en france
mais bon les cotations sont épuisés je
peux pas y aller j'attends que tout le
reste
parce que c'est pas naïf mais je vous
dis les choses très simplement vous avez
fait référence à la loisy l'immigration
il ya des éléments intéressants
il ya des éléments que je ne partage pas
mais il ya surtout un élément majeur
c'est qu'il ne traite en rien ce texte
de la question des flux
parce que c'est ça le sujet
l'immigration l'immigration c'est
d'abord la question du nombre et à aucun
moment il n'est traité la question des
flux et moi je vous dis une chose très
simple c'est qu'il ne faut pas être dans
le déni
la réalité aujourd'hui elle est connue
vous avez deux cent soixante trois mille
type de séjour qui on était
adresse qui ont été délivrés l'année
dernière 263 mythe de séjour c'est une
augmentation de 13,7 pour ça ça ne s'est
jamais vu à ce niveau depuis 43 ans et
c'est une tendance à la hausse
simultanément vous avez des demandeurs
d'asile vous connaissez la réalité le
gouvernement dix ans a mis en préfecture
ont été enregistrées en fait 122 me mais
peu importe
là aussi la demande explose vous avez la
situation des psys ce sont des chiffres
là cela vrai dire ça il n'y a pas de
débat s'est enrichie vous avez les
mineurs isolés c'est là aussi où ils
sont d'estimations très difficile 18 18
à 20 ans fait l'amalgamé qui me semble
vous avez enfin parce que vous avez
enfin les clandestins le gouvernement
annonce des chiffres sur 30 ou 40 et 70
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui sur la
dernière année connue il ya plus de 400
mille migrants supplémentaires qui sont
arrivés pour il souhaite arriver je suis
location choisi eh bien ça veut dire
qu'on ne peut pas continuer assure qu'
il y à des décisions à prendre
vous avez deux solutions soit vous
décidez de diviser par 2 par exemple le
nombre de titres de séjour qui a délivré
soit vous décidez de faire un système
d'accueil à point et vous avez ces deux
possibilités et la persuade que vous
l'avez pas traiter aller dans aucun on
va pas vous réconcilier là vous n'avez
pas trouvé de terrain d'entente merci
messieurs merci beaucoup d'avoir
participé à cette interpellation du
premier invité d'auditions publiques
émission qui se pensaient maintenant
avec l'arrivée de nos deux consoeurs
eq neuf donc oriane mancini de public
sénat et brigitte boucher de la chaîne
parlementaire assemblée nationale d'une
question mais surtout parce qu'en ce
moment il ya le bateau humanitaire
aquarius qui se dirige vers la france
avec 58 migrants à bord
ils demandent bien sûr être accueillis à
marseille faut-il accédé à cette demande
la réponse est non qu'est ce qu'on fait
la réponse est non
je vous le dis la france et l'europe
n'ont pas de leçon à recevoir en terme
d'accueil de réfugiés là l'union
européenne a accueilli il ya deux ans 7
124 mille et réfugiés demandeurs d'asile
à 7 124 mille il faut savoir se chiffre
à quoi il correspond
c'est trois fois plus trois fois plus
que le canada plomb évoqué un instant
que l'australie et que les états unis
n'en parle de pernant je le perds jamais
et bien sûr je vous le dis donc
la réalité c'est celle là et
deuxièmement la france n'a pas de leçons
non plus à recevoir dans ce domaine
parce que pour toutes les raisons que
migrants à bord de l'aquarium
on les accueille on les accueille pas
écouté puisque l'espagne et
une politique qui l'encouragé accepté et
bien qu'ils prêtent donc la route de
l'espagne simplement je vous mets en
garde sur ce sujet il faudra il faut
bien comprendre que il y à une
exploitation bien sûr que vous qu'on
connaît d'exploitation humaine que c'est
un véritable trafic instance émission
que les trafiquants attendez que les
trafiquants qui suivent très bien les
évolutions nationales sur ces sujets qui
génère selon une estimation assez
intéressante d'europol de près de 5 25
27 milliards d'euros
c'est donc une masse financière
considérable
eh bien il joue le mets en garde
observez bien les chiffres qui seront
certainement connu de ce qui se passe
comme le concernant la route des
migrants est-ce qu'ils vont toujours en
italie où est-ce qu'il s'adapte on
contourne pas l'italie et quelle est
l'évolution en espagne donc je le dit et
il n'est pas possible que l'on continue
à ce rythme et en attendant comme le
disait mme brigitte il ya urgence la
france dit à l'heure actuelle chercher
une solution européenne
est-ce qu'on peut toujours se défausser
sur nos voisins européens ce qu'il ne
faut pas assumer une part de
responsabilité comme l'a fait l'espagne
comme l'a fait mal mais c'est
effectivement une grande différence par
exemple avec le rassemblement national
moi je dis qu'il ya un défi migratoire
en france et en europe
mais la différence oui l'or lui sourit
l'emploi d'autres termes moi je dis il
ya un défi migratoire et vous parlez de
j'avais eu un début de l'émission
récente la pagaille migratoires et c'est
un défi simplement la solution elle ne
veut pas être que national comme le dit
le rassemblement national comme le dit
marine le pen
la solution aux défis migratoires et la
résolution de la pagaille migratoires
que nous connaissons c'est d'avancé sur
ses deux jambes
c'est par les législations nationales
parce que chaque état doit avoir le
droit de dire qui il veut ou qui peut
accueillir sur son territoire et en même
temps on doit marcher sur la deuxième
jambe c'est à dire une politique
européenne je vous dis très simplement
les choses c'est qui peut croire qu'il
est
va qui peut penser qu'il ne serait pas
logique que l'on se préoccupe des flux
migratoires aux frontières de l'europe
plutôt que d'attendre que les migrants
viennent à la vintimille à la frontière
française
j'insiste sur un dernier point le
commandant des gardes côtes turques pas
soupçonner d'être facilement à priori
bienveillant à l'égard de l'europe
autre cas il a évoqué il ya quelques
temps il a évoqué évoqué une
augmentation de 60 % 60 % sur les six
premiers mois de l'année des migrants en
empruntant illégalement la route
maritime pour rejoindre les côtes
européennes plus 60%
donc c'est pour ça que je vous dis il ne
peut prendre peut pas continuer à se
rendre à rester sur la question
européenne
oui avec le vote pour viktor orban vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure vous avez été
interrogé là-dessus au parlement
européen
on a vu les divisions de la droite
certains ont voté pour d'autres contre
d'autres se sont abstenus c'était votre
cas comment laurent wauquiez peut-il
rassembler une famille politique aussi
disparates d'abord eu des mots très durs
d'ailleurs échangé entre laurent
wauquiez valérie pécresse lors d'un
bureau politique non non pas du tout
j'étais vous le rapportez pas du tout
pas du tout en mettant des contrats
c'est très sain qu'il y ait un des bons
c'est votre réponse à briser daniel
division alors qu'on a pour mission de
rassembler m'écoutais je vous dis que
chacun prenne des initiatives c'est bien
que chacun ait des idées c'est parfait
que chacun des exprime bravo dès lors
que ça se passe au sein de la famille
c'est aussi simple que ça et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui a été dit précisément
à la réunion qu'elle intervienne et
déclarations publiques quand même jean
leonetti et laurent wauquiez ont affiché
des positions différentes
mais c'est un sujet compliqué comme je
vais rappeler tout à l'heure c'est un
sujet où il ce nom peut pas être
schématique
il faut être pragmatique réfléchir à ce
qui est le mieux pour l'intérêt général
et notamment en l'occurrence pour la
construction européenne maintenant si
vous voulez tout prix quelque chose du
quantitatif je vous le dis la majorité
nette des députés européens républicains
n'ont pas soutenu la résolution déposé
par la verte néerlandaise
mais tant est qu une partie de vos amis
donc je vais pas te fais vous dise on
est en train d'abandonner nos valeurs
c'est ce qu'ils disent les opposants à
la ligne wauquiez comment est-ce que
vous recevez cette année fondamentale
comme vous l'avez dit ce sont des
opposants donc c'est normal qu'ils
s'opposent mais je vous le dis vous êtes
pratiquement invoquait s'affiche
aujourd'hui avec angela merkel alors
qu'il s'affichait il ya quelques
semaines aux côtés de victor hubinon
mais c'est par contre un pardon vous
voudriez vous vous êtes très étonnant
parce que vous voudriez qu'on soit comme
des petits pois alignés comme des petits
pois et alors là vous y aura alors ça
c'est très monolithique 1 c'est pas non
nous on n'est pas une secte
on est une famille politique grande
famille politique dans lequel on débat
et puis un moment donné on prend ses
responsabilités et puis les choses
peuvent évoluer
moi j'étais très décidés à voter contre
la résolution mais de déposer par cette
élue verte
ce qui n'est pas péjoratif j'ai écouté
d'accord ce qui se passait j'ai j'ai été
attentif j'ai pas figé quand vous voyez
thierry mariani on en reparle
aujourd'hui parce que c'est marine le
pen elle-même qui le dit il pourrait
figurer sur la liste européenne du
rassemblement national est ce que vous
dites là les signes son départ son
exclusion mais écoutez c'est très simple
il n'y a aucune difficulté
il n'y a pas de délit d'opinion dans
notre famille politique pas de délit
d'opinion il peut y avoir un délit
d'action et donc et chacun pense ce
qu'il veut chacun peut imaginer ce qu'il
veut chacun peut avancer les idées qui
sont les siennes
et puis s'il y a du passage d'opinion à
l'action et bien il y aura naturellement
et des mesures mesures dans l'exclusion
et la gamme thierry mariani ne pourra
pas naturellement réseau dans notre
famille politique
nicolas dupont aignan vous a tendu la
main pour les européennes c'est hier
lors de son congrès puisqu'il présente
sa liste un puisqu'il sera tête de liste
avec sally sa propre liste est ce que
vous êtes pour une liste d'union comme
il vous propose lui vous et le
rassemblement national
oui c'est pas c'est une méthode je
connais bien nicolas dupont aignan je
connais ses qualités je connais aussi
quelques-uns de ses défauts ses
avantages de connaît depuis longtemps et
c'est pas
le rassemblement se fait pas au autour
du plus petit dénominateur donc nicolas
dupont aignan on cherche à avoir sa
propre structure
c'est son droit il a tenté une aventure
avec le front national qui qui
s'appelait comme ça à l'époque qui
visiblement n'a pas n'a pas marché n'a
pas donné les résultats et écouté que
chacun à l'occasion de l'élection
européenne exprime ses positions si
utile coller du poignon rejoint les
nôtres c'est à dire reposant sur deux
principes l'europe est indispensable
mais en le temps il est indispensable
qu'elles évoluent il est bienvenu mais
ce n'est pas dans l'autre sens que ça se
passe mais des fois c'est valable pour
lui paul nicolas dupont aignan c'est
valable pour le rassemblement national
c'est valable pour le parti socialiste
c'est valable pour la main aux électeurs
on tend la main aux électeurs et il n'y
a pas de sous directeur
encore une fois il n'y a pas de sous
citoyens donc nous tendons la main et
c'est à nous c'est à d'autres capacités
c'est tout le défi qu'est le nôtre de
convaincre que nous sommes nous une
alternative au bout voilà c'est
uniquement ses électeurs vous rejoindrez
et bien écoutez commençons déjà par les
écrire mon avis ça résoudra le problème
laurent wauquiez est fixé un objectif de
15% pour les européennes ça veut dire
que vous pensez déjà à perdre cette
élection wauquiez n'a fixé aucun
objectif donc déjà vous avez une
information qui est inexact mais nous
allons nous battre pour faire le maximum
on va se battre pour convaincre mais
vous savez n'oubliez pas d'où l'on vient
on est une famille qui a été fracturée
dans une famille qui a été condamné au
centre par les électeurs on a une
famille qui s'est naturellement divisés
parce que je vais vous apprendre quelque
chose de totalement ébouriffant c'est
que le succès feder et que l'échec
divise donc on à reconstruire et je
trouve peut-être un futur les élections
ça peut pas scellé le sort de l'europe
écoutez laurent wauquiez a été élu avec
près de 75 % des voix avec quelques
rectorales qui n'était pas négligeable
qui étaient cent mille nous il est à la
tête d'une famille politique est
aujourd'hui la première force
territoriales la première force au sénat
la deuxième force à l'assemblée
nationale est la 1ère ou 2ème force
militante réelle écoute et les lointains
comme le premier opposant vous avez vu
les sondages brice hortefeux il est dans
les choux quoi par rapport à marine le
pen ils ont écouté vous réjouissez pas
trop vite et je suis passé de fait il
arrivé qu'en septième position comme
opposants au chef de l'état
si vous voulez me faire dire qu'il ya
une marge de progression je vous conduis
je vous contredirai pas mais je pense
que pour être tout à fait clair que
laurent wauquiez a les qualités et
de compétences d'expérience et dans vie
qui font l'alchimie de celui qui peut
nous redresser il a les capacités les
qualités de rassemblement mais c'est ce
que je vous dis l'expérience dans vie de
compétences et je peux me jurez je peux
mesurer chaque jour combien il est
attentif à tendre la main à ceux qui
n'étaient pas forcément ses compagnons
graverie vous dites qu'il est très
attentif donc à la recommandation
première de nicolas sarkozy c'est à dire
qu'il faut savoir rassembler
s'affranchir il le fait bien sûr c'est
qu'il fait et d'ailleurs
moi qui suis un sarkozyste inoxydable je
vais pas changer je vais je vous le dis
tout de suite moi qui suis un sarkozyste
oxydable je suis aux côtés de laurent
wauquiez
donc la femme profite justement c'est un
retraité de la politique aujourd'hui il
est bien sûr attentif à sa famille
politique puisqu'il la nouvelle pac
lâcher il ay la lah contribuer à la
faire vivre et à la faire gagner puisque
nicolas sarkozy est le dernier à avoir
fait gagner la droite à une élection
nationale présidentielle et il est
attentif à sa famille politique
préoccupé par la situation de notre pays
mais comme il le dit lui-même il n'a pas
d'autres ambiances sondage ifop brice
hortefeux qui place laurent wauquiez en
septième position comme personnalités
politiques représentant le mieux la
droite derrière justement nicolas
sarkozy alain juppé xavier bertrand
valérie pécresse nicolas sarkozy c'est
le vrai patron de la droite
finalement laurent wauquiez n'a pas
réussi à s'imposer tu laurent wauquiez
est élu depuis quand il est élu depuis
quelques mois et s'en va on va pas on va
pas tout réussir tout reconstruire en
quelques mois vous demandez mon avis je
vous lis je pense que laurent wauquiez a
les qualités nécessaires pour permettre
le redressement de notre famille et je
vous le dis pas tellement pour lui
simplement pas tellement pour nous mais
parce que dans notre pays nous avons
besoin d'une majorité qui gouverne et
d'une opposition qui puisse être une
opposition ce que j'appellerais mois
positive c'était une opposition qui
approuve quand c'est bien et qui dénonce
quand ces naissances est nécessaire donc
c'est cela notre et c'est toute
l'ambition qui est la nôtre aujourd'hui
nous avons besoin de cela et on a bien
prix que la méthode mâcon qu'est ce que
c'est la méthode macron c'est de
chercher à tout prix avoir comme seul
interlocuteur l'extrême droite d'un côté
l'extrême gauche de l'autre pour être
tout ça tranquille c'est pas comme ça
que ça va se passer
moi je souhaite qu'il y ait un grand
courant social démocrate qui se
reconstitue qui s'expriment qui prépare
de son côté une alternance et que nous y
républicaine ou poissons aussi travail
de reconstruction un travail de
réflexion et un travail de propositions
ces salades et m la démocratie c'est la
confrontation des idées c'est pas
cherché à les chloroformé alors prête
une phrase nicolas sarkozy a un qui dit
à propos d' emmanuel macron lui exprimer
de la bienveillance à dire ça marche
également dans l'autre sens vis-à-vis du
chef de l'état me l'a dit ça peut donc
effectivement réussir mais ça peut aussi
très mal se terminer est ce que c'est
votre pronostic aujourd'hui je ne le
souhaite pas mais je vous lis quand je
vois les résultats de la croissance
quand je vois les résultats du la lutte
contre le chômage
quand on voit le niveau de la dépense
publique quand on voit l'évolution de la
dette
quand on voit tout cela et que
parallèlement aujourd'hui le pouvoir
d'achat des français a baissé comme ça
ne s'est jamais produit depuis 2012 je
suis effectivement très préoccupé ok le
défenseur de la france des territoires
de la france d oublier mercredi c'est à
dire après demain en ouverture du
congrès des régions les trois
présidentes d'associations pousseront un
coup de gueule contre la politique d'
emmanuel macron envers les territoires
est ce qu'il n'ya pas de leur part un
peu de posture politique écoutez quand
on voit la diversité de ceux qui
dénoncent la politique menée aujourd'hui
c'est précisément la démonstration que
c'est pas le cas parce que vous pourriez
me dire oui laurent wauquiez président
des républicains est dans l'opposition
encore une fois je vous dis nous sommes
autour de laurent wauquiez favorable à
une opposition positive qu'ils soient
qui ne soit pas systématique contraire
qu'ils regardent au cas par cas ce qui
est bien ou pas bien pour notre pays
mais quand vous voyez qu'il y avait
morin qui est issu
la famille centriste quand vous voyez au
delà de la rf au delà de l'association
des régions de france qui l'a
l'association des départements de france
dominique bussereau est beaucoup plus
dur avec son ancienne famille politique
qui ne l'était avec le gouvernement
j'observe qu'ils montent au créneau à
juste titre très fortement
même chose avec l'association des maires
de france et françois baroin le gel des
dotations alors qu'elles vont commencer
sous nicolas sarkozy et que la dgf
augmente
en fait il ya eu plusieurs risques
plusieurs temps et j'étais ministre de
l'intérieur et donc des collectivités
locales ce moment là j'avais décidé
effectivement à gel des dotations parce
que les circonstances l'exigeaient vous
avez laissé compte des circonstances on
viserait pas baissé ce qui s'est produit
par l'état céder malgré la crise on les
avait gelé et pas baissé mais simplement
les circonstances ont totalement changé
et le président de la république a
hérité d'une croissance qui est une
croissance qui n'a rien à voir avec
celle oui vous avez observé d'ailleurs
que la commission européenne a souligné
qu' on saurait certes en dessous de 3%
du déficit j'ai entendu m'isole
économique on était très heureux
communiquer sur ce sujet oui on sera à
2,9 c'est à dire ça vous le savez vous
c'est à dire à l'avant-dernier rang
européen juste devant dernière la
roumanie ce qui me rassure pas forcément
alors on parle de la ruralité vous vous
êtes mobilisés contre les 80 km heure
sur les routes
nationale à deux voies bon là on s'est
aperçu quand même qui a vu une baisse de
la mortalité routière cet été mais
peut-être pas totalement imputable à
cette mesure mais quand même on se dit
là ça va dans le bon sens est ce que
vous ne regrettez pas cette prise de
position et mes temps d'enrayer pas les
80 kilomètres quand on est passé de 20
mille mots à 4 milles séparent les 80
kilomètres quand même on est passé en
quelques années de vingt mille morts à
4000 donc il y à une amélioration il
faut examiner dans la durée je trouve
que c'est discriminant les 80 km heure
vous savez moi je suis élu rand'auvergne
c'est quand vous êtes entre aurillac et
pour en déduire que la motion il ya 96
km vous pouvez pas doit rouler à plus de
80 km/h c'est que vous êtes derrière un
camion
en tout cas je le souhaiterais alors
dernière question dès demain le comité
consultatif national d'éthique rendra
demain son avis sur l'extension de la
pma aux couples de femmes et aux
célibataires vous êtes favorable j'ai lu
avec intérêt ce déclaration des évêques
de france et je partage une inquiétude
pas simplement des avec les évêques de
france mais je partage une inquiétude
c'est que la pma en glisse à la gpa la
gestation pour autrui pourquoi je vous
dis ça parce qu'il ya quelques années ça
a été rappelé madame guigou quand elle a
créé le pacs et la dinepa question qui
est le mariage ensuite
bon il ya eu le mariage ensuite quand il
ya eu le mariage a dit aura pas plus il
n'y aura pas la pma ou en tout cas on a
été extraordinairement silencieux à
l'époque de françois hollande sur ce
sujet maintenant on nous dit qu à la pma
je dis attention à la gestation pour
autrui parce que moi je suis pas pour la
marchandisation des composants très
réservé important réservés on va voir ce
qui réellement évoqué est proposé mais
je vous dis ma position je suis très
réservé merci beaucoup merci mais non
merci brice hortefeux d'avoir été notre
premier invité pour cette audition
publique
merci ma c'est donc durant l'une servi
merci d'avoir servi de cobayes voit la
réalité nous vous remercions et la
semaine prochaine c'est stéphane travert
le ministre de l'agriculture qui sera
notre invité la semaine suivante ce sera
dit que le vélib est là
ministre de la justice donc pour
audition publique désormais donc chaque
lundi votre rendez vous sur les chaînes
parlementaires sur le figaro et avec la
fp a très vite
[Musique]
non